He was one of the most influential and talented
entertainers the world has ever seen.
But he was also one of the most complex – generous
and loyal friend, champion of the underdog,
devoted family man, womanizer and volatile,
loud-mouthed tough guy.
He lived a life on the edge – full of excitement,
danger and passion.
Sow, just how did the skinny Italian kid from
New Jersey became an international superstar
and the world’s first true multi-media artist?
In this week’s Biographics we go behind
the veneer to get up close with the Chairman
of the Board.
Early Years
Francis Albert Sinatra was born on December
12th, 1915 in Hoboken, New Jersey.
He was the only child of Italian immigrants,
Martin and Dolly Sinatra.
As such he was pampered by his parents, who
lavished the best of what they could afford
on their son.
Still, little Frankie grew up lonely and alone.
Martin Sinatra was a down to earth, easy going
and hard- working City Fireman.
His mother was just the opposite, driven,
involved in political issues and proving herself
the driving force of the family.
She belonged to every organization in Hoboken
and had a reputation as an extremely dominating
character.
While both of his parents worked, young Frank
learned to look after himself.
If he wasn’t home alone, he’d be wandering
the neighbourhood, where he quickly discovered
how to become street smart.
He grew up in a world of prohibition, bootleggers
and Speakeasies.
School was never a priority for the teenage
Frank.
He would often skip class to hang out in pool
halls, boxing gyms and on street corners.
He soon developed a reputation as a stubborn,
ornery kid who never backed down.
Often the subject of racial taunts, he would
never let an insult pass.
A friend recalled that once he and Frank were
walking down the street when someone said,
‘Hey you little wop,’ to Frank.
His friend told him to keep on walking but
an enraged Frank blurted out,
I’m gonna’ walk all over his face!
The only problem was that Frank didn’t really
know how to fight.
He got beaten to a pulp.
When his friend asked him if it was worth
it he replied . . .
Hell, yeah . . . He’ll never call me a wop
again.
However, two days later, the same thing happened
again – same guy, same result.
By the age of sixteen, Frank had ditched school
altogether.
He worked at a series of odd jobs, including
as a dockworker and newspaper boy.
But he often got bored and would quite a solid
job after just a few weeks.
When he walked out on his job working in the
refrigeration units of cargo ships, his father
had had enough.
He referred to his son as a ‘quitter’
and told him . . .
If you want to be a bum, go somewhere else
and be a bum.
Frank didn’t have to be told twice.
He packed up his few belongings in a suitcase
and took the train to New York City.
By now he had set his sights on making it
as a singer.
But no doors opened for the skinny Italian
kid.
He couldn’t find any employment at all,
let along a signing gig.
With nowhere to stay and no money for food,
he headed home.
Outwardly Dolly mocked her son’s singing
ambitions, referring to him as Mr Big-Shot
Singer before smacking him on the head.
But behind the scenes, she began visiting
clubs and asking managers to give her boy
a chance.
This resulted in a short-term gig in a Hoboken
club.
But the job didn’t last – Frank got into
a fight with the proprietor and was shown
the door.
When he was seventeen, Dolly and Marty lent
Frank sixty-five dollars so he could buy a
portable public address system and sheet music
arrangements.
This put him a step ahead of other aspiring
club performers.
Frank then began collecting orchestrations.
He later explained his strategy . . .
Bands needed them.
I had them.
If the local orchestra wanted to use my arrangements,
and they always did because I had a large
and up-to-the-minute collection, they had
to take singer Sinatra too.
In this way, Frank managed to establish a
foothold in the local club scene.
His hero was Bing Crosby, and he tried to
copy the Crosby sound.
But when he noticed virtually every other
singer out there was doing the same thing,
he made the decision to establish his own
unique sound.
Frank, Nancy & Success
In the summer of 1934, the eighteen-year-old
Frank met seventeen-year-old Nancy Carol Barbato,
who came from a poor family in Jersey City,
New Jersey.
Nancy was sitting on her front porch doing
her nails when Frank walked up to her with
a ukulele in his hand.
His opening line was . . .
Yo, what about me.
I could use a manicure too!
The spark was lit and the romance blossomed
over the next four years.
They lived one town apart and Frank would
frequently take the bus to visit and date
Nancy.
During these years, Frank was building his
singing experience.
Most gigs would pay around two dollars a night.
Sometimes he performed at roadhouses for nothing
more than a sandwich or cigarettes.
Frank’s first break came on September 8th,
1935 when he auditioned for a spot on the
NBC radio show Major Bowes and His Original
Amateur Hour.
The show was broadcast live from the Capitol
Theatre in New York City.
Frank teamed up with a group called the Three
Flashes and they became the Hoboken Four.
They performed the Bing Crosby hit ‘Shine’
and won a spot on the show, which was a 1930’s
forerunner to American Idol.
Listeners phoned in to vote for their favorite
act and the Hoboken Four proved so popular
that Major Bowes invited them to return several
times.
However, the radio show appearances didn’t
lead to any lasting success.
Frank returned to Hoboken and soon found himself
once more begging for any jobs he could find.
In 1939, Frank and Nancy were married.
Not long after that Frank was singing in a
club called the Rustic Cabin.
In the audience was Harry James, a big band
leader who was auditioning for a lead singer.
James was impressed with Frank’s way of
talking a lyric.
He invited Sinatra to audition the next day.
Although there were a lot of others who showed
up for the job, when Frank opened his mouth
the matter was settled.
He made his debut with the Harry James Band
on June 30th, 1939 at the Hippodrome Theater
in Baltimore.
The rest of that summer and into the fall
he toured with the band to enthusiastic audiences.
By 1940 Sinatra’s popularity was growing
steadily.
Then he switched bands mid-stream, jumping
at the chance to sign on with the more famous
Tommy Dorsey Orchestra.
The deal that Frank struck, though was hardly
in his favour.
He would give up a third of his earnings for
life, plus 10 percent for Tommy’s agent.
But all that the young Frank, who had recently
become a father, wanted was to sing and be
famous.
And besides, he would end up with more each
week than he was getting with the old band.
With the Tommy Dorsey Band, Frank travelled
across the country.
He ended up in Hollywood, California.
In 1942, the band, with Sinatra out fron,t
made a cameo in the MGM move ‘Ship Ahoy.’
With the band behind him Frank had built up
his profile.
He appeared on the radio, in concert halls,
on TV and in the movies.
By the end of 1942, he was one of the most
well known singers in the country – and
he had replaced Bing Crosby as Billboard’s
top band vocalist and cut his first record
with the band.
Going Solo
By the end of 1942, Frank had made up his
mind to go it alone.
He was clearly the star attraction of the
Tommy Dorsey Band, so, while they may have
needed him, he was more than able to hold
an audience by himself.
When he told Dorsey of his intentions, the
band leader was furious.
But Frank was determined and finally Dorsey
relented.
He did insist, however, that the contract
for a third of Sinatra’s earnings would
remain in place.
Frank decided that he would worry about the
contract later.
For now he would get out before Dorsey changed
his mind.
Sinatra made his solo debut on his 27th birthday,
December 12th, 1942.
In the audience that night was Bob Weitman,
manager of the Paramount Theatre.
He was so impressed that he asked Benny Goodman,
the King of Swing, if he minded having Frank
on a bill with him at the Paramount.
Goodman’s response was . . .
Who the hell is Frank Sinatra?
He would soon find out.
Sinatra’s appearances at the Paramount made
history.
It was the start of the type of hysteria,
epitomized by screaming and fainting girls,
that would later greet Elvis and the Beatles.
When Frank hit the stage, the theater erupted
with wild scenes that had never been seem
before.
In 1944, with his popularity soaring, Frank
became a father for a second time.
Frank Sinatra, junior joined older sister
Nancy at home while their father’s star
kept ascending.
His record sales topped the billings and he
was the most requested voice on the radio.
Losing It
With the end of World War Two, Sinatra’s
fame rose to yet another level.
He was contracted by Hollywood to star in
a series of musicals, each more popular than
the last.
Yet, in his personal life, things were starting
to unravel.
He was away from home so much that he hardly
saw his wife and children.
Then, in 1947, Frank met and fell in love
with the beautiful and glamorous actress ava
Gardner.
The two began a very public affair, which
lost Sinatra quite a lot of popularity among
the older demographic.
At the same time, the 31-year-old of crooner’s
voice was beginning to show signs of strain
and he was also being attacked by mainstream
media outlets for his support of liberal causes.
It was said that his fight against segregation
was Communist inspired.
Reporters also began claiming that he dodged
the draft during the war.
Leading the print assault on Sinatra was reporter
Lee Mortimer.
On April 8th, 1947, the two men came face
to face at Cirro’s Nightclub in Hollywood.
Frank went straight up to the reporter, called
him a ‘fruit’ and then proceeded to use
him as a punching bag.
Frank’s bodyguards quickly broke it up,
with Sinatra yelling . . .
Next time I see you, I’ll kill you, you
little degenerate.
Mortimer had Frank arrested and charged with
assault and battery.
The charge resulted in Sinatra’s gun permit
being revoked.
Mortimer later sued for $250,000, and the
case was eventually settled for $9,000.
Unwise Associates
Sinatra never seemed to appreciate that his
choice of associates could impact his career.
In 1947, not long after the beat up on Mortimer,
he went to Havana to meet with mobster boss
Lucky Luciano.
The mob connection was to stick to him for
the rest of his life.
Despite the affair with Ava Gardner, Nancy
Sinatra stuck by her husband’s side.
She gave birth to a third child, Christina,
on Father’s Day, 1948.
But the new addition did not bring Frank back
into the family fold.
His fascination with Ava was greater than
ever.
Unlike Nancy, Ava could match him drink for
drink, cigarette for cigarette and tantrum
for tantrum.
They were the ideal hard living couple.
That hard living had a price.
In 1949, Frank’s voice gave out.
That combined with public reaction to his
outrageous affair led to plummeting record
sales and chart numbers.
His radio show was dropped and MGM cancelled
his movie contract.
It looked like the show was over for the man
who had been called The Voice.
In 1951, Nancy finally divorced from Frank.
In short order, Sinatra married Ava Gardner.
He had formalized his love life, but it seemed
there was nothing he could do to resurrect
his failing career.
The public had become disenchanted with him,
viewing him as a washed up has been.
Coming Back
It was during his period of hardship in the
early 1950’s that Sinatra read a book called
From Here to Eternity by James Jones.
When he learned that a movie version was being
planned he became convinced that this could
be his road back to the top.
He set his sights on securing the role of
Private Angelo Maggio.
Frank secured an audition and then proceeded
to convince the movie’s producers that he
WAS Maggio.
He won the part – and gave the performance
of his life.
Sinatra won the Oscar for Best Supporting
Actor.
The following month he signed a recording
contract with Capitol Records – and his
career was back on track.
It appeared that losing his fame and then
clawing back had changed Sinatra as a singer.
He now wore his heart on his sleeve in his
performances, sharing his inner struggles
with the audience.
He became the first, and the best, musical
storyteller, and it was this ability that
brought him the male audience that he had
never had before.
In Sinatra they saw the tender tough guy that
they wanted to be.
Sinatra’s marriage to Ava Gardner was tumultuous
and it ended in divorce in 1957 – but his
career was going fro9m strength to strength.
By the late 1950’s, he was well and truly
back on top.
His Album Come Fly With Me hit Number One
and was on the charts for an impressive 71
weeks.
At the same time his movie career was hitting
new heights.
In The Man With Golden Arm he gave an extraordinary
performance as a heroin addicted misfit.
The 1960’s saw the emergence of a new brand
of popular music – rock and roll.
Realizing that he couldn’t ignore it, Sinatra
tried to accommodate by bringing out up tempo
albums.
In the early 60’s Sinatra also became a
staunch supporter of John F. Kennedy.
However, Frank had maintained his association
with key mob figures.
Attorney General Robert Kennedy was concerned
that Sinatra brought these criminal underworld
figures too close to the President.
He managed to sever the relationship between
JFK and Sinatra.
Sinatra’s last great movie role was 1962’s
The Manchurian Candidate, in which he played
US Army officer Bennet Marco.
After that he appeared to become bored with
movies and developed a reputation as a troublemaker
on the set.
His attention had switched to Las Vegas, the
new gambling capital of the nation.
There he and his buddies became known as the
Rat Pack.
Along with Dean Martin, Sammy Davis Junior,
Peter Lawford and Joey Bishop, Sinatra performed
a mixture of stand-up comedy and lounge music
at the best casinos in town.
Then, in December of 1963, Sinatra’s fun
loving existence was jarringly interrupted
when his 19-year-old son, Frank Junior, was
kidnapped and held for $240,000 ransom.
Sinatra appealed to Robert Kennedy, who called
in the FBI.
The ransom was paid, Frank Junior released,
and the kidnappers promptly caught, with most
of the ransom being returned.
In 1964, while filming Von Ryan’s Express,
Sinatra noticed a young actress named Mia
Farrow hanging around the set.
The star of a popular night time soap opera,
Farrow, at just 19, soon became Sinatra’s
constant companion.
The 30 year age gap provided plenty for the
gossip columnists to get their teeth into.
In 1965, the 50-year-old singer won an Emmy
for the best Television Special of the Year.
The following year he recorded one of his
most popular albums of all time, Strangers
in the Night.
That same year, 1966, Sinatra and Mia were
married.
However, Mia’s mellow hippie style was out
of step with Frank’s hard living ways and
the union only lasted sixteen months.
Following the divorce and finding himself
in danger of being yesterday’s news, Sinatra
began looking for a new musical direction
that would allow him to compete with the hard-edged
rock and roll that was popular at the time.
He found what he was looking for in the form
of the song ‘My Way’, written by Paul
Anka.
The song, which Frank recorded in 1969, has
become his anthem.
In 1970, to the shock of his legion of fans,
Sinatra announced his retirement.
He said that he was tired of show business
and wanted nothing more than to relax, read
and think.
But just as he prepared to take life easy,
life threw another curve ball his way.
He was summoned to a congressional hearing
keen to investigate his connections with the
mafia.
Lack of evidence forced the Congressional
committee to drop its investigation and the
heat went off Sinatra.
Retirement never sat easily with Frank and,
by 1973, he was once again on the comeback
trail.
This time his focus would be on concert performances.
He leapt back into the public consciousness
with a television special called ‘Ol’
Blue Eyes Is Back.’
From there he went on fill all of the concert
halls and big arenas across the country.
He sang directly to his audience dressed in
a fitted tuxedo – just as he had always
done.
In 1976, the 60-year old Sinatra married for
the fourth time.
His bride was 45-year-old Barbara Marx.
She travelled with him as he played to ever
growing crowds.
By the 1980’s the Chairman of the Board
was a bona fide icon.
He campaigned for Ronald Reagan, and helped
produce his second inaugural.
Then, in 1988, the 73-year-old paired with
some of his former Rat Pack performers.
The audiences loved it.
In 1993, Frank made use of a technological
innovation to produce an album entitled ‘Frank
Sinatra Duets.’
He sang along with 13 top recording artists,
though they were at different place and times.
The record became a number one platinum bestseller,
and outsold any of his previous recordings.
After more than a century he was back on top.
Sinatra lived out the last five years of his
life in relative quiet.
He was plagued by ill health, often going
into hospital with cardiac complaints.
Then dementia set in.
He passed away on May 14, 1998 at Cedar Sinai
hospital in Los Angeles with the official
cause of death being heart attack.
On May 15th, the Empire State building was
turned blue in New York and the casinos in
Las Vegas came to a halt in tribute to the
man who, very uniquely, did it his way.